it's a hard fight she fought hard Duane
dog Chapman is opening up about the loss
of his wife Beth Chapman it's just
incredible when you walk alone in the
bedroom and you're there and she was
just there two days ago Beth died on
Wednesday at the age of 51 after a
battle with cancer following her death
Dwayne spoke to Hawaii news now about
her final moments one of the last things
she said this is a test of my faith and
she had faith and then that was it she
goes you know there's things you go
through when you're dying like steps
like you do when someone you lose
someone you get mad at them and then you
go through all these steps well the last
step when you're dying is to accept it
and she said to me the other day honey
that last step I ain't takin Edie
learned Beth was surrounded by her
family including the couple's children
when she passed here's what Dwayne said
about that moment when she had an attack
I didn't know anything to do but say in
Jesus name and hold her and when I said
in Jesus name she said say it again say
it more and then she you know told the
girls and everybody with her mouth and
stuff she came out of it a couple times
and I love you are you guys all okay
don't worry but she never accepted it so
amazing
this is totally unbelievable Duane
described the minutes leading up to and
since Beth's death as quote terrible and
he said that despite her long fight with
cancer the timing of her passing was
unexpected for a few years do that
someday this day would come we get it
came very unexpected really fast and we
didn't even all of her clothes are
exactly where they were
every everything we didn't prepare the
66 year old reality star also spoke
about how his faith is helping him to
deal with the loss of his wife I hope to
god there's a God I have tried to be a
be a godly I always have trained myself
what would Jesus do and I hope I'm not
just talking to myself I hope there is a
God and if there is almost see my how do
you get and that's all we can do is hope
Dwayne said he believes Beth is still
with him I love her so much
as Lazarus laid Jesus said he's not dead
he sleep with
my final words are Beth isn't dead she
sleepeth the family had been open about
Beth's health struggles over the last
few years in November 2017 they told
fans that her cancer had been completely
removed only for its her return in 2018
Beth underwent emergency surgery last
November to remove a mass in her throat
and began chemotherapy the next month
but was hospitalized again in April Beth
was however able to film episodes of her
and Duane's new WGN America series
Dogg's most wanted my wife the love of
my life is fighting for her life that is
sure to be an emotional season and I
just want to say that here at ET our
thoughts are with Duane and his family
as they grieve until next time I'm
Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]